remember pokemon cards you could collect
them and use them in battles with other
players
now there's this game called axi
infinity that's built off that same
concept but this time these game
characters are nfts and you can make
real money from owning them axi infinity
is an example of a play to earn game a
new model in online video games that
allows players to generate an income
from earning cryptocurrencies or nfts no
more will the game studios be able to
capture 100 of the revenue so how do
play to earn games work and what can
this model teach us about the metaverse
play to earn is just one percent of the
global video game industry but it has
garnered an enthusiastic community that
believes in the future of nft video
games and its potential to shape the
metaverse gaming's pushed a lot of
industries forward in its time i think
it's going to be the forefront of nfts i
think it's going to be the forefront of
the metaverse the concept of buying
virtual goods in video games isn't new
but play to earn games turn these goods
into nfts which allows players to sell
them for a profit nfts or non-fungible
tokens are essentially digital deeds
that verify that an item is authentic
and unique
axi infinity is one of the more popular
play to earn games it hit its peak in
2021 going from about 38 000 daily
active players in april to 2.5 million
in december according to the company so
how do players make money in this game
one way to earn cryptocurrency is by
winning battles first one to defeat the
other opponent first wins another way is
by selling your game characters to other
players on an nft marketplace
brent vitt who goes by his gamer handle
cairo says he started playing axey
infinity because of the potential to
make money in
uh prior video games that have played
it's the top 0.01 percent that is
getting the money from the game they're
they're playing and winning in all the
tournaments and in this it's anybody and
everybody can come and earn a couple
bucks he says last summer when the value
of the game's cryptocurrency was at its
peak he was making about fifteen hundred
dollars a month from axi infinity about
the same as the monthly income from his
day job in kansas this is just like the
screen that shows me transferring that
the in-game currency into eth meanwhile
axi infinity makes its money mainly
through fees for example it charges a
4.25 fee for every trade made on the
marketplace
so what can play to earn teach us about
running an economy in the metaverse a
virtual realm where people can work play
and shop
first it shows how owning digital assets
as nfts allows people to buy and sell on
a marketplace much like they would on
the stock market
vit says he once flipped an axi game
character on the marketplace for over 4
500
understanding whenever things are like
over and undervalued is like a very very
valuable asset to have in this space axi
infinity says over 4 billion dollars
worth of axes have been traded on the
marketplace to date
sarah needleman a tech reporter for the
wall street journal says players may
choose to hold on to their axes for the
long term but as with all things crypto
it's still too early to tell how
valuable or permanent those assets will
be even if if a game goes away and you
buy something that was made for that
game will it have value down the line
could it work in another game or in some
other virtual environment and that's
just not clear second play to earn shows
how the earning aspect can encourage
people to learn about crypto and nfts
when we look at the player base like
almost 50 of them have never even had a
bank account and are totally new to
crypto this model also incentivizes
current players to educate others about
the space for example in axi infinity
players developed a scholarship program
to recruit new players who may not have
the money to join on their own
axiomfinity says it's run into an issue
of players earning crypto in the game
and then cashing out their earnings
without participating in the marketplace
economy doesn't work if everyone is you
know extracting more value than that is
being come in and i think that people
are kind of missing that point of nfts
in blockchain because they're so focused
on all of the earnings
third many metaverse companies promise
interoperability or the ability to
travel between virtual spaces with the
same virtual assets and some play to
earn games are already experimenting
with this idea to some degree for
example splinterlands a play to earn
card game allows players to trade
digital goods on marketplaces on two
different blockchains that are connected
by a bridge i think over time if there
are ways to take a virtual item that you
earn in a game and use it outside of
that game that might make these items
more valuable because you could use them
perhaps in a work setting if it's
something cosmetic or they could apply
to multiple games axi infinity says it's
looking toward interoperability as well
but it's unclear how safe it is right
now there are so many hacks like bridges
are you know going under all the time
several hundreds if not billions of
dollars have been lost like this
everyone wants to have this like
interoperable metaverse but in reality
kind of getting to that point is going
to be exceedingly difficult
despite its passionate fan base play to
earn has experienced pushback from some
longtime gamers who say this is just
another way for companies to squeeze
money out of them nfts have also been
under fire lately over concerns about
the security of its technology a lot of
nfts have been created based on
copyrighted material or content without
the permission of the actual creators i
think it's possible that there'll be
some sort of government regulation in
the nft space
play to earn is still evolving but some
companies already see it as part of the
future of gaming farmville maker zynga
and assassin's creed creator ubisoft
entertainment are among the first big
publicly traded video game companies to
say they are experimenting with the
strategy it's likely that games will add
nfts because right now they're already
selling virtual goods other game
companies have expressed interest in it
they haven't actually made a move yet as
more video game makers contemplate
adding nfts tech experts say the ability
to buy and sell nfts in the metaverse
will be key putting gamers in an
important role in the metaverse you're
going to see gaming as being an
integral part of the entire ecosystem i
don't think that we go towards a future
where gaming isn't related to
player owned economies and assets that
are tradeable by the players yo let's go
that was super hyped thank you so much i
appreciate it let's go